grand reporter rt france régis le
sommier bonsoir régis après trente
années de règne d'omar el béchir la
transition politique au soudan est
clairement en péril les militaires sont
en train de réussir ce qu'ils
ambitionnaient de faire depuis longtemps
évidemment oui il y as comment il ya une
dix ans une commande noyau dur de
militaires qui qui souhaitait reprendre
le pouvoir et qui n'a pas du tout
accepté de cette transition démocrate et
mme démocratique donc qui a accepté
finalement de risque et le bleu
le mano à mano avec le peuple puisque
est-ce qu'on voit finalement c'est que
les soudanais s'était mis dans l'idée
après ce règne que vous me dites de
extrêmement lourd d'omar el béchir qui
avait règne quand même qui est qui était
d'un des pires une steam des pires
dictatures d'afrique à l'époque faut
savoir que c'était aussi ses 30 ans
ça a été le théâtre par exemple de
l'accueil de d'oussama ben laden
quelques ici est qu'à un moment trouvé
refuge au soudan donc on était dans une
dans une dictature du régime dictature
islamiste également donc voilà la
transition est bien elle est là elle
était naissantes elle commençait à se
faire et il y avait évidemment des
militaires derrière qui ambitionnait
justement d'y mettre un terme et c'est
un peu ce qui s'est passé avec quand
même beaucoup de questions encore en
suspens où se trouve le président amdocs
aujourd'hui donc la junte 10 qui a pris
le pouvoir dit qu'ils ne sont pas en
danger la prendre les principaux
ministres également ont été kidnappés
véritablement et donc qu'il ya un vrai
un vrai problème avec quand même des
moyens de levier
de la communauté internationale on aime
donc réunir au cvo conseil de sécurité
de l'onu mais surtout
elle peut justement les américains déjà
ont décidé de suspendre l'aide de 2 700
millions de dollars qu'ils octroient au
soudan tous les ans une partie de cette
aide d'environ 365 millions ont déjà été
versés donc mais la suite risque de ne
pas l'être non plus l'europe c'est à
hauteur de 52 millions
ça c'est des sommes qui n'ont pas encore
été versées qui pour le moment n'ont
être bloqué en attendant justement
peut-être une issue favorable ou en tout
cas mais si la junte au pouvoir se
maintient il est évident que voilà c'est
une manière de couper les vivres à temps
qu'est ce que peut faire le soudan
qu'est ce que peuvent faire les
militaires ils ont l'egypte au nord
l'ethiopie mais on sait que l'ethiopie
et le soudan sont très liés mais
l'ethiopie est engagé donc dans cette
guerre pour notamment dans cette région
sécessionniste du tigré ya l'arabie
saoudite l'oci à l'est tiens voilà qui
est un soutien donc mais est-ce que ce
sera suffisant pour régler un certain
nombre de problèmes
comment dans le pays rien n'est rien
n'est sûr on a vu la position différente
de la russie la russie a des intérêts au
soudan différentes seul rhino
international y avait même un projet
d'installation d'une base militaire
russe au soudan tout ça est en gestation
qui dit hein
je cite un et le ce coup de force est le
résultat d'une politique ratée et d'une
ingérence étrangère
d'ampleur il ya du vrai dans cette
analyse ou c'est de bonne guerre mais je
pense que c'est une question d'intérêt
chacun d'église derrière une façade de
d'expression de da termes de commandes
de ccc le langage diplomatique qui parle
en réalité il ya les intérêts des uns et
des autres qui sont clairement exprimés
la transition démocratique quand on n a
passé trente ans sous une dictature
effectivement ça peut être que empirique
et voilà et ça évidemment ça ne
satisfait pas tout le monde mais on voit
qu'il reste toujours au soudan des
habitudes justement héritées de l'ère
l'air bachir et qui ont tendance à
persister et qui se manifeste encore une
fois sous la forme d'un coup d'état
militaire quid de la population dans
tout ça parce que le soudan rappelle est
l'un des pays les plus pauvres du monde
les soudanais sont dans la rue
d'ailleurs on dit ce soir que des tirs
soient entendus actuellement dans les
rues de khartoum
la population prise en étau va être
prise en étau avec une population qui
avaient cru elle je pense dans une
grande partie de 2,2
ajustement voir autre chose à comment
est-ce que le pays depuis donc le
départ de le 11 avril 2010 9,2 d'omar al
bashir espérait justement qu'ils
puissent ce que parce que c'est la rue
aussi il y avait déposé le dictateur est
donc là il y avait je pense d espoir et
désespoir qui malheureusement sont en
train d'être réprimée puisque les
manifestations étaient interdites des
tirs des tirs oui que va-t-il se passer
est ce que la population qui s'est
révolté vais avoir les moyens de
continuer à faire cette pression nous au
contraire ça va être la répression tous
azimuts c'est ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours et évidemment c'est
très critique et tout le monde doit
regarder ça et va suivre cette histoire
de façon attentive merci beaucoup régis
le sommier d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur sur rt france